in der früh um 6 uhr tagwache und normal
funktioniert es hängt auch sehr gut
doch jetzt haben wir relativ mir gewesen
war gestern ist über mitternacht
ausgegangen
[Musik]
und noch immer kommen jetzt einen
frühstücken und das frühstücksbuffet ist
eigentlich sehr gut
[Musik]
österreich ist ob sie auch sagen wie man
durch eine schlammgrube sein und sonst
nur ein haufen träger auf unserer
kleidung und auf unser dorf gelebt haben
und wie man hinten die kameraden schon
sechs ist der schwerpunkt alles wieder
trocken link putzen und schauen dass
einen entwurf wieder blitzblank sauber
[Musik]
[Applaus]
heute haben wir ein leistungstest lassen
müssen das war bei kilometer fünf
minuten das
[Musik]
wertlos